Speaker 1: All right. Let's not spend a lot of
time on this. And much of what we're talking
about today is developing live. And so I'm going
to do the best I can to tell you what's happened
over the last 24 hours. And then we have to move
relatively quickly to the next steps in this
indictment of Donald Trump. But Donald Trump last
night exploding untruths, social. Making it clear
he's terrified and making it clear he doesn't
actually care about law and order. Demanding the
indictment of Alvin Bragg. With what evidence? On
what charges? Wait a second. I thought your whole
problem was that this indictment of you isn't law
and order, but now you're just calling for the on
a whim indictment of the guy investigating you
trump tro thing to troth essential quote. Wow.
District Attorney Bragg just illegally leaked
the various points and complete information
on the pathetic indictment against me. I know the
reporter. And so unfortunately does he. This means
he must be immediately indicted. What now? If he
really wants to really clean up his reputation,
he will do the honorable thing. And as
district attorney indict himself. There you go.
He will go down in judicial history and his Trump
hating wife will be, I am sure, very proud of him.
Trump not stopping there with random demands for
people to be indicted. Continuing to talk about
special prosecutor Jack Smith TRO thing, quote,
speaking of leaks, special prosecutor Jack Smith,
what did his name used to be? Leaked massive
amounts of information to the Washington compost.
This is illegal and I assume this radical left
lunatic, much to the chagrin of his Trump hating
wife and family, will be prosecuted. He is a
totally biased capital T thug who should be let
loose on the Biden documents hidden in Chinatown
and the 850 boxes secretly stored in Delaware,
which Biden refuses to give up. Biden is guilty of
obstruction. I am not so think of it claiming that
the problem here is that law and order isn't being
followed in the investigation and indictment that
he is now subject to. But on a whim, within just a
couple of hours on troth. Social truth essential.
I don't even know what it's called at this point.
Trump demands the self indictment of Alvin Bragg,
demands the indictment of special prosecutor Jack
Smith, and declares Joe Biden guilty of crimes
absent any evidence nor any criminal proceedings
of that sort. And this is just another reminder,
my friends. They say they are for law and
order, but they are not. They say they are
for due process, but they are not. They are for
whatever is convenient at the time as applied
to them and then whatever is convenient at the
time as applied to their political opponents. And
if those two things require a complete cognitive
dissonance and a divorce from any stated principle
of consistency, then they don't care. And you
know what? They get away with it. Because as many
of you have written to me and said, David. The
right doesn't care about hypocrisy anymore. The
right doesn't care about double standards. So it's
not even worth pointing them out to them because
they aren't fazed. It's whatever is convenient
for me and not for the. And that is it. Well,
we are going to learn very quickly indeed what the
repercussions are of the crimes with which Trump
is accused. This is only the first indictment
today. It is now being circulated that another
indictment in Georgia could be coming at the end
of April, which we will talk about tomorrow. These
are truly unprecedented times, not because anybody
in the investigative community has done anything
wrong, but because we are now starting to see
accountability for a unique and unprecedented one
man crime spree. That was the former president,
Donald Trump. At this critical moment in American
history and a critical moment for independent
media. We continue to be primarily funded by our
viewers through the membership program, which
you can find at joint Packman dot com. You'll
get the Daily Award winning bonus.
Speaker 2: Show, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Regularly
displaying that I have no soul.
Speaker 2: David Pakman does
not have a soul is not a soul.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Candace. If that makes you
curious about what's happening on this bonus show,
you can sign up at join Pacman dot com
and you can, of course use the coupon code
indicted a very clear coupon code
one that requires no explanation